I love my job because it makes a
difference to people's lives
[Music]
what attracted me to the job was the
opportunity to develop and grow within
the council
issue the consents and help build the
city I really love seeing how excited
people get when I tell them that they
can finally build their dream home it
makes me really proud when I see the
buildings that I played my passion
I love my job because of the pie
today in politics but most of all I love
the knowledge that we are fluent
speakers lives on a daily basis and we
really do make a difference in our day
is the same and imagine the complexity
of things like three waters and land
transport and responding to growth to
the work in our libraries where we're
shaping children and young people's
minds we actually have a role in
placemaking in community building I
never plan to work for local government
and just fell into us but now that I'm
part of a local government family I love
it I enjoy the people I work with and I
love leading leaders to come up with
ideas and make a difference in the
communities that they live in in the
communities they care for I love that I
can be chief executive of central
Hawke's Bay district council and at the
same time be a man to toe gorgeous
little children I never imagined that at
36 I've been charged for team that hits
session and paper on the city
one team of 40 that are able to go out
there and
love a great service to people of the
city it's
cousin penetrates and a smile no matter
what
appreciate the council is helping me
grow they are supporting my university
studies and helping me go further with
my career I love going to work every day
because I'm passionate about the natural
environment and I'm passionate about
people in our community and I just
combined those three things every single
day
I love working with kids and I love
seeing the light go in their eyes and
they're really engaged the natural world
whether it's doing a planting or
teaching about our nature of wildlife I
love watching them make that connection
with the world around them I love having
the community groups reach whatever
their objectives may be it's the animal
control pest we control all restoration
a lot of people in my team we all fight
over who has the best job in the world
but I know that's me
I love the role within District Council
within local government because you have
a real contact with the community we're
all a family we're all focused on making
a change for the community central
government play a big part in that with
a number of MPs visiting whare they can
see at grassroots level what makes a
difference
warrior has a larger portion of e we are
focused on the land the people in their
children's children's potential so it's
exciting time to be in local government
and really the sky's the limit if you
can launch a rocket from warrior you can
do anything
[Music]